(audience cheers)
- You are, like every time you come here,
you look so dapper.
- Thank you so much, you look great too.
- Well someone, a whole team
of people makes this happen.
I don't look like this in general.
- Well, same.
- No, I feel like you probably
look like this at Target.
- Okay, I appreciate-
- Yeah, you do.
- I appreciate your optimism
when it comes to how I look.
- You totally do, probably.
- Thank you.
- But wait, so New Year's just happened.
How do you celebrate New Year's?
- I have absolutely no
expectations for New Year's.
(Kelly laughs)
I have no lists.
- No bar.
- I have no, I call
them like, at the very,
because what is it, New Year resolutions?
- Yeah, do you do those?
- No, obviously not.
I've tried.
Every year you try, and
every year you fail.
Not to be a fatalist, but
I'm just terrible at them.
- I don't like to say fail.
I like to say just not there yet.
- Right, right, right, right,
working on it, we're working on it.
- [Kelly] Working on it, yeah.
- I don't love to work on
things, so I'm just gonna-
- I love working on things.
- You do?
- Yes!
- So you stick to a list?
- I will stick to the list,
and it doesn't matter
if it takes a decade,
but I'm still doing it, yeah.
- Wow, okay great.
- I just like to have, I
like goals, I like, yeah.
- Yeah, well I also now like goals,
and want to set them for myself.
- I do, I don't know why.
I think it gives me
purpose, like to go like,
okay, this is the thing I'm gonna work on.
- I did a thing last
year where I said, okay,
I was gonna walk every day,
and I was gonna add like
an extra five minutes
every time I walked.
- Okay.
- Yeah, and then 15 days later?
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- I am on my couch.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no hiking, there's no nothing,
and the shoes are just
sitting by my front door,
waiting to be used.
- You're from the most
beautiful place ever.
Canada's so beautiful to hike.
- It is very, yeah.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, didn't do that in Canada.
- Especially British Columbia.
(audience laughs)
Just a hard no, I love it.
So wait, you and your
dad are both part of,
it's called the Order of Canada, right?
I've talked about this with your dad.
You're now both a part of it.
- Yeah.
- This is a big deal in Canada.
- It is, it's like, I don't, it's like,
I don't know, am I a knight now?
Like, I don't know what that is.
- I think so.
- I'm gonna just be knighted, I guess,
is what it comes down to.
You know, it's like a great honor.
I will say, yes.
It's like a tremendous honor,
and I don't wanna discredit
Canada, obviously.
- [Kelly] No.
- But my dad has been
on here so many times
that I feel like that
has been the great honor.
And now it's my, on top of like-
- [Kelly] I love your dad.
- I should be wearing my pin, actually.
- Aw, I love your dad.
- He loves you so much.
- I, ditto.
I love him so much.
- That is the great honor.
I mean, you know, a country
recognizing you is great,
but being here is also great.
- Aw, I love, has anybody,
is there ever in the Order of Canada,
is there like a father-son
or a mother-daughter?
- I actually have no idea.
- I think that you might be the first.
I'm just saying it.
- [Dan] Let's just say we're the first.
- Let's just say it, yeah.
- I think we should.
- Breaking glass ceilings.
(audience cheers)
I like it, I like it.
- I think you get another
one when that happens.
- [Kelly] Yes, I think you're just
a special, special member.
You get another pin.
- A Guinness record sort
of right at the end,
just on the bottom page.
- Well, wait, speaking of Dan's dad,
he told a story about Dan the
first time he was at our show.
So let's see that.
- Uh-oh.
- Yeah.
- My son was 15,
and he was going to come
with us in Los Angeles.
We went down for the premiere.
- Yeah.
- Of the movie.
And the night before the premiere,
he said he was on the phone call
with his friend back in Toronto.
And they said, "Well, what's going on?"
He said, "Well, I'm going to
the premiere of 'American Pie'
tomorrow night with my folks."
And the friend said, "Oh,
don't see it with your folks!"
(audience laughs)
- Did you not, did you not go?
- No!
Absolutely not!
- Oh my god.
- Absolutely not.
No, I called a friend.
They had just seen like an
advanced screening of it,
and said whatever, run
in the opposite direction
of wherever your parents are
in relation to that film.
And I did.
And I never, I have yet
to see it with them.
I did end up seeing it.
For most of my high school life,
people thought the movie was
like a biography of my life.
- Yeah.
(audience laughs)
That is unfortunate.
- Which is really unfortunate.
- That's unfortunate.
- Because I would've killed
to have had a life that interesting.
(audience laughs)
- And why apple pie?
- There was no pies.
- Yeah.
- I don't even know about the
ingredients of an apple pie,
but that's a whole other conversation.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- My, I think my mother's the opposite.
I would be fine, I
think, in that scenario.
I think my mother would die.
- Okay, you would be fine.
- I'm very open.
I'm very open.
I will talk to my mother about anything.
So will my sister, and my mother hates it.
- Wow!
(audience laughs)
- Like with a capital H.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- I don't have that dynamic.
My dad is very sweet,
but no, there was no-
- I have no problem.
I could talk about anything with her,
like literally anything, and I try,
but she is just not, she is like,
why are, your mouth is moving-
- She's the opposite of
what this movie was to me.
- Yeah, she's not into it,
so I would've gone to the premiere.
Anyway, your dad's in a
(bleep) cool, awesome movie.
I would've gone.
- Yeah, you know, it's a weird thing
to grow up watching your
dad just hand out porn
to some other kid.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
(audience applauds)
- That was a scene from
his movie, "Good Grief."
You can see it now on Netflix.
So, explain the movie for everybody.
- Oh, it's like, it's kind
of a 180 from my TV show.
- That's what I was gonna say.
Did you purposely kind of
do a departure from comedy?
- Yeah, I mean, I was never like a comic.
I wasn't a standup, I didn't,
I just happened to write a funny show,
and play sort of a funny character.
- You have great comedic timing,
so I disagree with that statement.
- I just, yeah, so I
think there was a desire
after 80 episodes of writing
and performing comedy
to do something very different.
So, this is a movie about
grief, and about friendship,
and my character loses his husband,
and it's really an exploration of,
that's the amazing Luke Evans.
- Yeah.
(audience whistling)
- Which, yeah, it's like tough to cast.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
It was a tough casting choice.
But yeah, it's basically about
how this group of friends
react in the aftermath of
a very meaningful death.
And I just haven't seen a lot of movies
where friendship was the
center of the conversation.
- Yeah.
- And that was the love story.
It didn't require like, romance.
- But that is a love.
- It's the greatest love.
- Oh my gosh, I wouldn't have survived
several situations in my life
without my friend circle.
Like, do you have that circle?
- Yeah, yeah, of course,
and I just felt like that
deserved its time in the spotlight.
I feel like so many movies,
rom-coms, and certain dramas,
it's all about the romance.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the friends kind
of sit on the sidelines.
But in life, I feel like,
at least in my life,
my friendship is so much
at the center of my life
that it just felt like a nice film
to kind of explore the
meaning of friendship.
- Yeah, is it, 'cause there's
a lot of depth to this,
and a lot of grief.
So like, so is that hard for
you to do, like on camera?
- Yeah, my dog died five days
before I wrote the script for this movie.
(audience awws)
- Oh no!
- Yeah, and he was getting old,
and I knew that I was making this movie.
And so for like, the
year leading up to it,
I would like sometimes
catch him on my bed,
and be like, don't you dare.
It's too sad to like, go
through it without you.
And then he, yeah, he
passed away five days
before I started, got the
green light for the script.
And I think there's sometimes
where things happen in
your life for a reason.
And I don't know if I'd be
able to write the script
for this movie with
the same level of like,
vulnerability, or the same
rawness if it hadn't happened.
And so it's a, I feel very fortunate
to have made something
that is a celebration
of my feelings for him.
I lost my grandmother a year before that,
so it was a kind of a catharsis of feeling
when it came to her.
It has nothing to do with them,
but it has everything
to do with the feeling.
- Yeah, and it's a hard feeling,
'cause I think we
compartmentalize a lot, you know?
You compartmentalize what's going on,
and then all of a sudden
it'll randomly hit you.
- Yeah, and grief is this weird thing
where I feel like everyone
is going through grief of some kind.
And I think while you're going through it,
you can feel very isolated by it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Whether you're doing it right,
whether you, whether
there's an appropriate way
to grieve something.
- Or length of time.
- Or length of time, again,
and so, this movie is really kind of
explores the idea of that,
and what grief really means,
and is there a way to do it properly?
So, it was my way of
kind of working through
1,000 questions that I
had going on in my head.
- That's the best art though,
when someone's actually
in that raw moment,
and what comes out of that is you could,
it's transparent when you're the viewer.
So, oh, I heard this about
your grandma, actually.
She loved your first story?
Your very first story that you wrote?
- Oh yeah, yeah, there
was a, I wrote a story
about a young princess
that traveled to Russia.
It was a very epic
story that was not good.
And yet, I remember her
sort of pulling me aside
saying that she was very moved by it.
She was very touched by it.
And that, I think, is true love
when you can read something terrible,
and really, I think genuinely
convince your grandchild
that you think they're great.
- Oh my god.
- So yeah, it was one of the
early votes of confidence
in my writing.
- Oh my god, that's
what I say in my world.
It's like, if you see someone sing
and it's just like so off key,
but you're looking at
their significant other
looking at them, and
you're like, that's love.
Yeah.
- Because they don't hear it.
- No.
- They hear wonderful, like.
- Yeah.
And it's kind of the same
with like, people's kids too.
Like, sometimes you look at a
kid and you're like (gasping).
(audience laughs)
- I thought you were gonna-
- Whoa!
(audience applauds)
And the parent, the parent
is like behind the stroller
being like, aw, this is.
(audience laughs)
- Love, and then you go, that is love.
- That is love.
- They see through it.
- It's also why I'm not
having kids, clearly, so.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
We love them.
- But okay, so you, this
movie was set in Paris.
Did you do that on purpose,
just so you could hang out in Paris?
- Kind of, a little bit.
(Kelly laughs)
- Sorry.
- I mean, it's set in London and Paris
for a variety of reasons, obviously,
but also because, why not?
No, it was a, it's a lovely
story about like some,
you know, I play kind of
a guy that moved there
to kind of rebuild my life.
And it's, oh, that's our lovely cast, and-
- What a great cast.
- Jamael and Ruth and Himesh,
and we just had the greatest time.
And yeah, we traveled to London and Paris.
Paris?
The food at lunch on a movie in Paris.
- Oh no.
- All I care about, most
of the time, is food.
- I know, that's what I'm saying.
I would gain so much weight.
- It was, you'd break for lunch,
and there would just be tables
as far as the eye can see
of like, breads, and pastries,
and meats, and veg, and quiche,
and things that I actually believe
that we were more productive in Paris,
just so people could break for lunch.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience laughs)
- They were like, must get done.
- Yeah, yeah, we gotta
get, let's wrap this up,
'cause we have to get to the lunch table.
- They can do a charcuterie board.
I love all that, I can survive off of it.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yes.
- And then, apparently,
they used to also serve wine at lunch.
- Why not?
- Well, and then apparent,
from what the French said,
the American productions came
and really took advantage
of the wine at lunch.
(audience laughs)
So they had to scrap the wine at lunch.
- They're like, but
Americans weren't used to it,
so they just smashed in
the second half of the day.
- Yeah, it was, it wasn't
as elegant as the French,
I think, at the end of the day.
- So, okay, I think that
since it's based in Paris,
I thought we could play a game about-
- I would love that.
- Movies, like in Paris.
- Oh, okay.
- Are you down?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
(audience cheers)
- Well, you can see Dan's movie,
"Good Grief" now on Netflix,
and you can see me whoop his
behind next, stay right here.